donald trump en opération reconquête
chez noir un bras maudit après la montée
des tensions commerciales au printemps
2010 9
les deux hommes cherchent à relancer les
partenariats entre les deux pays
le président américain souhaite
renforcer ses relations avec l'inde pour
contrer la montée en puissance de la
chine dans la région depuis plusieurs
mois responsables indiens et américains
négocient les contours d'un nouveau
traité commercial
la visite de donald trump pourrait
accélérer les négociations sans pour
autant permettre de signer un accord
majeur mais le président américain l'a
sur les négociations sont en bonne voie
nous pouvons conclure un accord
commercial avec l'inde mais je garde
vraiment le gros accord pour plus tard
nous préparons à très gros accord
commercial avec l'inde
je ne sais pas s'il sera conclu avant
les élections mais nous aurons un très
grand accord avec l'inde un apaisement
des buts et cinq mois plus tôt donald
trump avait participé à un rassemblement
de la diaspora indienne en l'honneur de
narendra modi lors de sa visite
officielle aux états unis une présence
inhabituelle pour un président américain
qui démontre la volonté de donald trump
de s'afficher en bons termes avec le
premier ministre indien
l'occasion également de s'adresser
directement à la diaspora indienne
je suis également venu exprimer ma
profonde gratitude à l'égard des
quelques 4 millions d'indiens américain
à travers le pays
vous enrichissez notre culture
vous défendez nos valeurs vous élever
nos communautés et vous êtes vraiment
fier d'être américain et nous sommes
fiers de vous avoir la visite de donald
trump en inde a pour but de renforcer sa
relation avec le chef d'état indien mais
elle permet également d'envoyer un
message à la communauté indienne aux
etats-unis huit mois avant les élections
présidentielles en 2016 lors du suffrage
précédent 80% de la diaspora préféré
soutenir hillary clinton